"The Tomorrow" War is a topsy-turvy time travel
adventure starring Chris Pratt fighting aliens.
From the fate of its heroes to the future
of mankind, here's the ending of "The Tomorrow
War" explained.
When we meet him, Dan Forester is obsessed
with becoming the scientist he'd always hoped
to be, making his family proud in the process.
When that plan doesn't work out, Dan begins
to spiral.
He eventually learns that his insecurity over
his path splinters his family ... before his
own death in an accident in 2030.
For Dan, the future he made for himself — the
one that began the night he was told he didn't
get his dream job — was a bleak one.
"You just, you never seemed happy with your
life."
But fighting in the future war, returning
safely, and defeating the White Spikes before
they could spread seems to have turned Dan's
outlook around, if not his whole life.
The movie doesn't tell us exactly what his
future holds.
We have no idea if he's able to parlay his
heroics into getting his dream job after all,
or even if he manages to survive past 2030
in the new future he's helped to carve out.
But the good news for Dan is that he's finally
found the real purpose and meaning in his
life, thanks to losing his daughter in the
future.
For however much time he has left, Dan is
focused on his family, and that seems to be
enough.
Though he jumps into the future and then back
into the present, Dan Forester's "Tomorrow
War" story is actually fairly straightforward.
The same cannot be said for his daughter,
Muri Forester, who grows up to become a respected
and tireless military research scientist and
ends up working with her dad in an effort
to save the world.
We follow Dan for the whole film, but we see
Muri in fragments, and her ultimate fate in
the film means her future is rather ... complicated.
We know that during her childhood, Muri was
very interested in science, so it makes sense
that she grew into a key researcher in the
fight for humanity's future.
But by the end of "The Tomorrow War," future
Muri isn't just dead — the future she was
a part of has been changed by her father's
heroism.
The last time we see her in the film, it's
as a child, still full of hope and promise.
As with Dan, we don't know if Muri's future
still holds these things.
The film doesn't tell us what she grows up
to be after the future war is wiped away.
"The Tomorrow War" ends with the future everyone
has accepted being wiped away, leaving plenty
of unanswered questions for our heroes and
for the world at large.
Many of these unanswered questions are positive
things, leaving open endless possibilities
now that humanity is no longer going to be
wiped out in 30 years by an alien horde.
But one question might linger over at least
one character like a terrifying eventuality.
When he meets the future version of his daughter,
Dan learns that he and his wife, Emmy, eventually
divorce, in part because of his own personal
insecurities throughout the 2020s.
When he arrives back in the present, recommitted
to his family, Dan seems resolved to keep
that from happening by being a devoted father
and husband, but can he ever really know that
he'll prevent it?
What if he and Emmy are just destined to have
a finite marriage?
What if some other disappointment comes along
to make him spiral again?
Dan can work as hard at being a husband and
father as he wants, but some things might
be inevitable ... or not.
Early in "The Tomorrow War," we see Emmy Forester
using her own skills and expertise to help
in the war effort, serving as a trauma counselor
for veterans who've returned from their seven-day
tour of duty in the future.
Though they survived their fight with the
White Spikes, many of these people are missing
limbs, and the psychological damage runs even
deeper.
It's a major mental health crisis amid the
larger crisis of the battle for the future.
By the end of the film, the fight for the
future is seemingly over, but that doesn't
change the experiences of the veterans who
made it back to their present.
The battle is over, and for those in the future,
it never even happened.
But for the soldiers who survived, the scars
will remain forever.
In a world eager to move on from crisis, will
those veterans be taken care of?
Hopefully, people like Emmy will keep fighting
for them because their wounds didn't vanish
when the White Spikes did.
Early on in "The Tomorrow War," as the human
race of the present is just learning to comprehend
the future threat and the time-travel system
that warned them about it, Dan and his new
friend, Charlie, make a discovery.
All the soldiers who've been sent back to
train them for future battle are quite young,
so young that they haven't been born yet when
the film kicks off, presumably to avoid some
kind of paradox in which they run into their
past selves.
It's the same reason why soldiers from the
present who are sent to the future are all
people who will be dead by 2051.
It just keeps things easier.
"Why don't we just jump back earlier in the
war?"
"The jump link doesn't work like that."
This system makes sense, but as the film ends,
it leaves a few lingering questions, particularly
since the time-travel mechanism in the future
is destroyed.
What happens to those future soldiers?
Since the future has presumably been changed
by destroying the White Spikes, it's possible
they were never born at all, so do they just
... vanish?
It's one of the most fascinating wrinkles
in the film's world-building.
Late in the film, after he returns to the
present and finds himself cut off from the
future, Dan goes looking for the origins of
the White Spikes in the hopes of preventing
the future war from ever happening.
With help from Charlie and one of his brightest
students, he realizes that the White Spikes
went undetected not because they were stealthy
but because they actually landed on Earth
centuries in the past.
In fact, they were frozen in Russian glaciers
for 1,000 years until the ice finally thawed
out and freed them in the late 2040s.
This means that climate change and the continued
thawing of polar ice around the globe contributed
to the awakening of the White Spikes and helped
cause the invasion.
Humanity didn't know it, but by failing to
address the Arctic melting, they sealed their
own fate.
This development is essentially presented
as a throwaway explanation in the overall
plot, but it leaves the human race with some
major future wisdom that they perhaps didn't
have before.
The White Spikes may be gone, but the ice
is still melting, and that creates future
danger of a very different kind.
Word of the future war arrives quickly, without
warning ... and with a lot of catching up
to do on the part of humanity in the present
day.
One day, everyone's enjoying a soccer match,
and the next, the whole world has to prepare
for a war 30 years in the future.
In the universe of "The Tomorrow War," we
learn that once proof of the future threat
is established, the world's governments leap
into action.
Countries band together, uniting against a
common enemy on a scale never before seen
in human history, and institute a global draft
to ensure there are enough soldiers to battle
the White Spikes.
It's a massive effort, but what happens when
the future war ends?
As the film closes, the human race is celebrating
the end of the White Spike threat, but they're
also facing other issues.
The present has endured massive loss of life
from the war, and there's also the ongoing
collective trauma of the survivors.
Families are shattered, incomes lost, entire
communities ravaged.
It's a good time for the world to remain united
even though the larger threat is gone.
The question is ... will they?
The White Spikes, the menacing aliens that
dominate "The Tomorrow War," are set up as
seemingly perfect predators.
They're heavily armored, fast, strong, and
they even have offensive weapons in the form
of the spikes they shoot from their limbs.
They spread across continents in a matter
of months, overrunning the world through a
combination of aggression and a strong reproductive
cycle.
They do all this after sitting in stasis under
ice for a millennium, and just one small colony
manages to reproduce and conquer an entire
planet.
So, even though that colony has been wiped
out, the governments of the world have to
be wondering, where did the White Spikes come
from, and how do we stop them from trying
to take over the planet again?
Are they on other planets in our solar system?
Is there a chance we could encounter them
again?
Could more colonies still be in stasis somewhere
in the world?
There are a lot of lingering questions about
these fierce predators, and the world needs
answers.
When Dan and his team arrive at the White
Spikes crash site near the end of the film,
they discover a crashed spaceship, but it
doesn't belong to the Spikes.
No, those fierce aliens were actually cargo.
The ship itself was piloted by a pair of more
humanoid-looking aliens who've since died
but were very clearly in charge of the ship.
Sadly, because they have to blow the whole
vessel up to stop the White Spikes, Dan and
company don't get to preserve these alien
bodies, but their very existence poses a number
of questions.
How did they crash 1,000 years ago?
Was Earth their target, or did they end up
here accidentally?
Were they using the White Spikes as weapons,
or were they for something else?
Are there more of them out there already on
the way to our planet?
Whatever they are, more than one alien species
poses a potential threat by the end of "The
Tomorrow War," and they might just be biding
their time.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.